asks is there anyone whose point of view
you don't enjoy writing
i know i like uh i i like
all of the characters and even even some
of the ones who are like kind of sleazy
and uh um
disagreeable people but you know when
when i'm i am writing
them i get inside their skin and
try to see why they do the things they
do because i
i don't think anybody gets up in the
morning saying what evil can i do today
i think people who do evil things
or cowardly things or you know they all
have
they don't have reasons for it they all
have their justifications
why it's right and and so you crawl
inside your skin and then
you try to present it from their point
of view um
each point of view has its own
particular challenges though
and it is it does take a certain amount
of changing
years to to go from one to the other you
know like
tyrion is uh is witty
he's very clever and he makes clever
comments
um and that's good um
but i have to think up all those witty
lines
and you know i sometimes
said i'm not as witty as tyrion well of
course actually i am as witty as tyrion
because
i think of everything every witty thing
that tyrion says is something
i thought however i don't think it up as
fast as tyrion
i i you know tyrion tosses off these
lines and then
i think uh in real life you know i think
there's something we need to say
three days later you know i'll be three
days from now i'll think of something i
could have said in this interview that
would have been really cool
have to be constantly revised in order
to uh
make it wittier and make his dialogue a
little sharper and the first drafts are
never quite there and you know i have to
polish them a little time and change
something and then then of course
sometimes you know you get it
oh this is just you change it and then
you say well maybe the first version was
better
and you go back to the first version no
the second word was better
oh wait a minute what about this version
you come up with a third version
so that's a particular challenge of
writing tyrion is getting the dialogue
as sharp as i possibly can on the other
hand
writing character like victarion
victarion is not clever uh
mkhitaryan is is is not
the sharpest sword in the armory um
but that has its own challenges because
you're you know you as author know
what's going on what you're telling it
through the eyes of someone who doesn't
really know what's going on uh
he thinks he knows what's going on but
he's actually kind of
not entirely right so
um and he also has certain unpleasant
personality uh flaws
that come out and sometimes you're
writing sort of
ugly thoughts that he has um
that you know would uh appall your
mother
um so that's that's another challenge
that's a that's a different challenge